a lady helps you to get up maybe you
discover it's the love of your life so
although you know well it was a pure
contingency but the way you experience
it all the your life if you're a
romantic like I am you are waiting for
that moment we have to live with this
contradiction so philosophy is like
Falling in Love absolutely
[Music]
welcome to have a light gets in thank
you very much although immediately as a
hegelian I must correct you you know
something happens with already and
then telling Hegel till death
point of German idealism
light was associated with subjectivity
subject is a light darkness is outside
in chaotic nature but already there are
some hints in can't his basic late text
on religion within the reasons of within
the limits of reason alone selling of
course and Hegel the symbol of the inner
symbol metaphor for the innermost core
of the subject is night Darkness the
night of the world Hegel says this
wonderfully in some of his early texts
that is this night if you look somebody
in the eye you see objects but cut into
pieces just floating around and
everything emerges out of this so I
would say how does the light get in in a
bad way light obfuscates this core of
the subject where both Hegel and
trailing refer to Jacob Jakob berme and
other
Mystics but speaking of Darkness you
have a famous uh Hegel quotes that you
like to to use lately which is that the
Owl of Minerva flies is at dusk at the
end of something of an end of the period
but Hegel has also this other quote
where he says that philosophy is its own
time comprehended in thought and I was
wondering how do you reconcile those two
questions
I think he even says I think both things
in the same paragraph what he means is
that
we live in a certain epoch
but all we can do in our thinking is to
grasp the
conceptual structure at its purest of
this epoch and for this
reason so philosophy always comes too
late Hagar is fanatically against any
plans for the future and so on
and for this reason
I'm a total partisan of another
materialist reversal of Marx into Hegel
Hegel was at this level very modest he
openly admitted we can make some guesses
and so on but Mark was way too idealist
for Hegel Marx knew that generally at
least if you have the right subjective
position the exploited workers we can
somehow get
he was not a full determinist Marx but
the let's call it objective tendency of
History like if we don't screw it up
something may be better socialism
communism away class what Hegel would
have said and that's why we we need
where Hegel is at his best is he takes
the beginning of a great Epoch where
there are all the promises about biker
Cuban and shows how more or less
necessarily it turns wrong his big
example was of course French Revolution
Freedom Terror but I think Hegel would
have felt like fish in its own water in
later time look at the second half of
19th century
not in the colonies it's another story
but in Europe it was a big era of
progress even in Russia they abolished
servidents in Germany Bismarck
introduced
first elements of global Health Care
retirement plans suprajet and so on so
the idea was things go on then you get
the Great War the first world war which
was I think the event in some sense much
worse than second world second world war
just an after effect and sorry that I
talk too much but you know who is here I
must admit it although he was not such a
great theoretism as marks you know who
one of the few who predict that even the
second world war in 1880 already angles
in some letter saw the signs he says the
way it goes now Germany will want a
stronger place in dividing Colonia lead
the world so there will be a World War
and we he was just lucky I think with an
incredible foresight Engel says this war
will end up maybe with Revolution at at
least in some country like Russia
and then he says there will be around 10
million dead people the official number
today is nine million eight hundred and
then in an ingenious Edition he says
that if Germany loses maybe a decade or
two later Germany will trigger Another
War so that's the Paradox of Martin
Hegel they were not idiots in concrete
predictions they were often very
accurate but back to Hegel
what why in 20th century would be ideal
ground for Kegel look what happened
October Revolution great promise sorry
comrade Stalin is there raising up then
we have fukuyama the end of History we
are there haha sorry we know where we
are today this is the Hegel we need
today it doesn't mean we should do
nothing but hegel's lesson is
history repeats itself not in the sense
of repeating the same but things go
wrong necessarily and only in the second
attempt maybe you can get it right so
hegel's whole idea was not to turn
against French Revolution because of the
terror but how to do it again
at a higher level whatever so don't you
think we terribly need this hegelian
pessimism today like Hegel
we all the theorists of global
capitalism Global liberal Market they
are describing a forum which is already
disappearing if you ask me here I agree
with my friend who doesn't agree with me
on many other things Jan is very fakis
who said what is happening now he is not
moralistically complaining but yeah this
weak figures like Bill Gates or Elon
Musk and so on this is no longer old
liberal capitalism there are many
theories like
Neo federalism
corporate authoritarianism but something
new is emerging and we have are
disoriented we don't really know what is
happening you know the last text Hegel
wrote was his uh some notes on the
English Reform Bill
he appears reactionary there he warns
against expanding the
universalizing the right to vote but
hidden in this and some pearls he forces
a future in which because the old
Estates hierarchic Society will
disappear
the rebel
will be
controlled and manipulated by what he
calls Rich Rebel the ruthless nouveau
rich and it will be even worse in this
sense and he was right if nothing else
today it's happening this is happening
what is philosophy making sense of today
given what the mainstream philosophical
movement is for the most part analysic
philosophy in the English speaking world
what is it capturing is it capturing an
aspect of our time you know what's my
point here that I nonetheless have some
hopes that a new era is slowly beginning
also in
philosophy till
20 years ago I would say it's
approximate we had a clear division
between analytic philosophy which also
included got mixed with brain sciences
and so on so I know in some American big
universities you had these Paradox that
you feel dissect the brain of of a red
its philosophy if you study hegelitz
literature they were saying so we had
this uh attitude best expressed in the
introduction to the last book by Stephen
Hawking
although he simplified it very much but
at some point he was right the result of
this what we called discourse analysis
predominance in Continental orientation
is that many basic let's call them
naively big metaphysical questions does
the universe have an origin or end do we
have free will
you look in Sciences for the answer does
the universe have an origin that's what
quantum physics cosmology is do we have
free will that's what that's what a
cognitive scientists are trying to do on
the other hand the Continental
orientation got more and more lost into
what I call transcendental historicism
that you the many others were doing the
same thing but the clear case is for me
here somebody like Michelle Foucault if
you were to ask him for example what I
will be asked in a debate now is there
objective morality his answer would have
been all we can say is that to raise
such a question is Possible only within
a certain episteme a certain Horizon of
meaning such a question wouldn't even
have meaning in medieval times where in
some sense morality was objective
inscribed into so he was for him German
have this beautiful word
which means you cannot go behind the
ultimate Horizon is what Foucault calls
episteme The Horizon of knowledge
through which we observe in reality and
interact with it and there are of course
great examples like with modern science
it's not just I believe in science that
it's more true
is that this difference emerged between
reality out there and meaning we project
into it so it's not just the science is
more truthful the meaning of what is
nature of what is truth changed and so
the result unfortunately is that
the so-called deconstructionism or this
histories is hermeneutics all in it all
you can do is
describe analyze the Horizon of meaning
within which me move and let's call them
naively the big questions are simply
dismissed as irrelevant I see Trends
lately to move Beyond this at different
levels and with many of them I am even
caught in polemics for example this
object-oriented ontology and so on and
so on but I think the general direction
is the right one and my second point
the series that I find Hope isn't it
that still now by now I mean 30 40 years
the latest advances in digital
manipulations brain sciences and so on
till now with all the new problems like
nuclear explosions somehow basically the
old morality
still
fitted you could rely to it but with
what is happening now for example that's
why pandemic interested me we you know
that the big debate must yes or no
social distances this was at some level
appropriately philosophical debate if we
obey all the injunctions of doctors
Healthcare institutions are we still
free or not do we still retain our human
dignity so here is my optimism as bad as
things look we will need philosophy more
than ever
because again in our everyday problems
it began with abortion it's basically
almost a philosophical problem you know
is it already a living being do we have
the right or not so these are not good
news because as Hegel knew it already in
his early system there's literally
height system of Customs
times when philosophy is needed are
difficult times are times of trouble but
I don't worry about us philosophers
becoming useless because that's the last
point I don't expect from philosophers
Solutions the big problem today is
rather that when we confront new
phenomena
we formulate we approach the problem in
the old terms I think the biggest role
philosophy can do today is to correct or
at least make us think of how we
approach the problems that's why as a
philosopher for example I oppose deep
ecology
because I think it's secretly still
radically anthropocentric
you know it's uh it's this idea that
somehow rivers and forests have their
rights yes but they don't know it so we
humans even if they emphasize we are
just one of the species but we are the
only ones who have the universal view
this is I think and don't underestimate
this the big role of philosophy today to
not to offer Solutions but to enable us
to ask the right questions
mystifications begin already at this
level when we are aware of a problem but
formulate it in the wrong way
so one of the big Frameworks that
philosophy and science have been
operating under uh for you know decades
now is this kind of like some kind of
form of individualism and some form of
reductionism the idea that the the
relevant unit in any kind of explanation
is the individual and if we want to
understand it we need to kind of see how
his parts are working and so on no no
here I think I hate this quick quick too
fast generalization from Sciences but
okay with all my limitations and so on
but isn't the big lesson if we draw
maybe it's then this lesson maybe it's
too quick
generalization of quantum physics that
precisely
we should abandon entire materialist I'm
not but this old idea that the ultimate
realities empty space and and some
stupid particles just floating there no
you have oscillations you have
ontological ambiguities waves and so on
so uh I don't think that everything that
is is in interaction of individual
entities it I find it much more
productive
what some Quantum physically strikes to
tries to give Forum to the idea that
waves oscillations are somehow
primordial and that particles are
interactions of multiple waves this I
think again at all levels even at Social
level we can abandon because here adorno
I don't believe in his negative
dialectics but he makes a wonderful note
somewhere where he says as you said
today's
approach to society moves between the
two extremes either individualism the
starting point are individual
individuals and then complex structures
emerge through their interaction or he
refers of course to Emile durkheim this
organism's approach Society is the
primordial fact and under certain
conditions
different types in each condition of
individuals emerged and then you know
what is a dormant solution to this it's
not the usual the
electrical synthesis and of that but he
says
this very antinomy between individualism
and social approach organisms is the
deepest characteristic of our social
reality itself this is not just an
antinomy it in itself has its own Moment
of Truth and taking this through today
on the one hand we are always addressed
like individuals that neoliberalism
ultimately you are responsible and so on
on the other hand we talk about this big
impersonal objective Trends and so on
and so on what about the subjects
because again there are sort of two main
ideas floating around one is this kind
of extreme naturalistic way of thinking
of the subject as just an evolutionary
product of each or even third grader but
if you go to the extreme they even say
subject in the sense of subjective
experience of your spontaneous activity
free will is as they call it users
illusion and then you have different
ways to move up like some people some
analysts allow for the idea that through
this complexity complex interaction of
pre-subjective Parts something which
maybe is not simply an illusion can
emerge at the higher
level
so at uh sorry finish your question no I
was going to ask you how do you see
philosophy contributing to this and can
can science
in some way contributes answering the
question what is the subject or is that
a pure philosophical question that we
need to address separately again it
depends on what do you understand as
subject because usually subject is
spontaneously conceived as
an agent with this
spontaneity of action I look around I
decide I do what I want and so on and so
on but I think that in psychoanalytic
sense here Freud has some thing to say
subject is not primordially this
spontaneity of the free will but it's a
set of basic unconscious decisions the
Paradox of Love is the same as
intelligent theology new as the Paradox
of believing in God kirkegaard says if
somebody says kirkegaard said that it's
somebody claims I study different
religions and Christianity convinced me
our best arguments no he said that's the
worst idea you only see the argument for
Christianity if you already believe it's
the same with love I admire whatever
your legs your smile sorry for these
sexisms because I'm already in love so
love is on the one hand a free decision
if there is a free decision it's to
freely fall in love but it never happens
in the present it's or at some point you
have already fallen in love it always
has this retroactivity and here I would
say
that a different type of subjective
Freedom emerges which escapes both this
Earth phenomenology of Consciousness and
a scientific
not and scientific
naturalism can I take it back to
something he said at the beginning of
this answer about
sort of some limits of a naturalistic
approach to the subject and you brought
up love for that as an example yesterday
in your debate with Harare you said I'm
a naturalist not an idealist what do you
mean by that
I simply meant it this is a very complex
question and I consciously took the path
of as I tastelessly referred to it a
couple of times like I will not pull and
he did not pull the knife out you know
no I Am Naturally just in the sense that
I don't think there is the higher force
or whatever that everything there is in
is in some broader sense nature but for
me this doesn't mean that there is a
zero level like what I mentioned before
empty space and some stupid particles we
never the lesson of quantum physics for
me is that we never really Reach This
zero level that that uh that uh at zero
level we don't have clear image of empty
space and particles what we get is some
kind of wave oscillations and now they
are making great advances I like the
hypothesis with new Quantum physicists
and stupid to really see the scientific
value but for example the Italian guy
Marco rovelli I think you should get him
here he's been to the festival he's been
because I read I must admit it just some
of his popular books his point is that
space and time are themselves Quantified
like you cannot
like in that famous uh Paradox of
infinite subdivision no there is a
minimum Quantum of space and time and
then in a very intelligent way
he tries to develop the concept of
matter
out of this primordial tension of time
space and space and he goes even further
claiming that space
has priority here
and now again it's not up to me but what
I like is just that
the problem is not we know the basic
level of it to what we have to reduce
think and then it goes more and more
complex I think that at the ground level
we get a big mess
not just because of the limit of our
knowledge
that reality is in itself I like to
repeat this motive ontologically open
not fully
constituted and so at this level
I try it's high speculation I don't know
how it works I try to
not the way Roger Penrose does he is
also one of those who try uh
to somehow
locate the opening for human Freedom
already at this Quantum level but not in
this no Roger Penrose is more
intelligent but some simplistic Quantum
guys simply say oh if there is
contingency blah blah doesn't this open
uh
space for Freedom no because never
forget freedom is not contingency
freedom is free decision determination
if you just okay it's not contingent
really but if you leave your decision
like you through a through a coin in the
air which side this is not Freedom you
don't decide freely it's just
contingency and I am heavily working on
that because uh my okay I will give you
now a direct formula which will probably
mean nothing but that's the I hate these
words metaphysical core of my work now
I take Buddhism very seriously but the
ultimate Buddhist wisdom is nirvana void
and I had wonderful debates in China in
Japan with Buddhists and we ended up in
a deadlock because from my standpoint
Maybe I'm Wrong I appeared an idiot to
them but from my standpoint they avoided
the key question which is the hegelian
question not
can we really break out of this wheel of
Desire into the primordial peace void
Nirvana
but how did this primordial peace get
Disturbed how did appearances
appear emerged and this is what also
Hegel says the problem is not this old
kantian man what is behind appearances
the problem is precisely precisely how
can from something flat stupid just
reality out their appearances emerge and
I'm going to the end and I claim
but they told me that some Tibetan
Buddhists have an idea of him that it's
not just Nirvana and then false
appearances that there is a deeper
tension in the void in Nirvana itself
it's somehow in an infinite
self-contradiction so it's a beautiful
Theory which finds way in I love them
with modern European uh Mystique by
modern I mean in the old-fashioned sense
uh Meister Ecker and then Jacob
who said that isn't this a beautiful
answer you know why God created the
world to avoid his own Madness it was
kind of a work therapy you know so I'm
looking
for me the ultimate answer is not
provided by Buddhism this eternal peace
or whatever
but some kind of a radical almost
pre-ontological Gap disturbance that's
what comes really first
and I try to elaborate this and then my
idea is that in human subjectivity this
primordial Rift
Gap somehow
re-emerts but it's very speculative
so in some way your naturalism as it
were sees the primordial ontological
state of reality finding its way all the
way to the human subject yes yes yes
this and I'm not saying that it can find
its way only in human subjectivity I am
not in this sense anthropocentric as if
you know the whole of the world was this
kantian position too that the world was
really created Consciousness somewhere
reality was created so that we can fight
our moral struggles in it no but in some
sense count is right you know only in
what sense that we always read the past
from our present and from our human
experience we just should never forget
that this was a total contingency like I
believe it's a good hegelian in total
contingency like who knows are we aware
I said this yesterday people don't like
to hear it that we humans emerge out of
double triple catastrophes can you
imagine what must have happened on our
Earth millions of years ago for us to
have deposits of coal and oil can you
even imagine this catastrophes we now
know today that the asteroid which kills
dinosaurs created the conditions for
Humanity so the art for me is to
be totally open towards the future in
the sense of things happen contingently
but
nonetheless not to forget that every
present moment at least in our human
universe
retroactively
interprets the past in a teleological
way somehow you know it's like falling
in love again I'm sorry you walk on the
street sorry for the tasteless example
but not vulgar you you sleep on a banana
peel a lady helps you to get up maybe
you discover it's the love of your life
so although you know well it was a pure
contingency but the way you experience
it all the your life if you're a
romantic like I am you are waiting for
that moment we have to live with this
contradiction so philosophy is like
Falling in Love absolutely absolutely I
think philosophy is falling in love in
the sense that
it's uh you know what Harari I would
have many things to debate with him but
that I sincerely agreed with him where
he said freedom
is freedom is is uh
never a conclusive State now I am free
freedom is the very Eternal doubt am I
free or not and so on and I think it's
the same with love the moment you don't
doubt your love the moment you think you
know why you are in love it's finished
so they both have this this uh this uh
Retro Retro activity and what I find it
so sad today I hate it my friend friend
Allen but you pointed this out in
English and in French and in some other
languages not in all the verb a very
correct one which uses to fall in love
and one should give to the verb fall all
this radicality you go all of a sudden
boom you fall what I hate so much I
don't believe it I'm here all
with this idea but I have different
needs maybe poly Armory works you are
good for this you are good for that no
sorry this is not love this is your
different Niche and so on love is
something else it's much more
non-conditional and what I fear is that
you know when I was young there was a
more conservative
erotic pedagogy
to be to have multiple partners was
considered pathological even
psychoanalysts were usually anal what
are you why are you running if you're a
man sorry for the male chauvinist and
heterosexual why are you running from
one woman to another what are you
escaping from your mother or what now in
Argentina maybe the most psychoanalyzed
country in the world when I was there
they told me and I finally said the
decadence that it's the opposite if you
jump from one woman to the other for
women also if you change Partners it's
considered normal if you are faithful to
your partner they say oh my God this is
pathological fixation we have to analyze
it and so on I think beneath this it's
not just Liberation no it's a sad
redefinition of love in the term of your
needs maybe you need more dish more of
that and then maybe only different
people can do it this is not love I
don't make a compromise here I want this
passionate love but not you know where
I'm not romanticist
I I understand uh Orpheus and eurydice
you may don't know it but the German
cultural critique is now old 30 years
ago Klaus devilite
provided a wonderful interpretation of
why does bringing her up from Underworld
why does Orpheus look back it's not that
because he was very eurydice I made some
sounds he was worried the idea is that
when while she was following Kim and he
was prohibited to look at her back when
she was following him up by divine grace
he started to have serious question like
okay this is my ideal but wait a minute
to live with this woman who will wash
the dishes all that stuff what if I get
disappointed isn't it better to get rid
of her and I retain her as an ideal I
write poems but I can do what I want
with other women so
she looked he looked back bye bye I will
celebrate you all my life but I will be
rid of you that's not true love true
love is that true love the consciously
somewhere doesn't idealize the partner
true love is not idealization you expect
all the small imperfections
and you love the person even more
because of this
thank you very much
[Music]
debates courses and articles visit the
Institute of Art and ideas click the
link on screen now to IAI dot TV